about an hour ago
the c-squared podcast hosted by fabiana
carwana and christian carrillo
they just went live with an episode
discussing all the ongoing chess drama
and they did give a lot of insightful
and remind me later and informative
takes
but there was something said
towards the end of this podcast
which was absolutely disgusting and
pretty much indefensible
now a few days ago i was interviewed on
their podcast i think the episode will
drop tomorrow
and at the beginning of the episode we
played a game
in the staffer gambit which i posted to
my channel yesterday
and after that game
fabiano made a promise to me
i made a promise to eric
and then i completely went back on that
yesterday i played the title tuesday
and
i was analyzing the stafford gambit
before the tournament no you weren't
yeah i was
and then i realized that white wins with
like any move
and like i i don't want to diss eric's
opening but i couldn't bring myself to
play it it was just like i couldn't
analyze it every move wins it was
terrible
as much as i want to cry
listening to that clip
it is kind of true the staffer gavit is
objectively a terrible opening
especially if you're a 2800 level gm
but a promise is a promise
and i feel
absolutely betrayed
so i actually want to devote this video
to
trying to convince
fabiano caruana
to play the staffer gambit at least once
in the title tuesday
and i want to share all the fun
interesting
exciting offbeat dubious traps
that black can pull
that work at the highest levels
that have worked against aronian kamsky
hikaru and hopefully by the end of this
video
[Music]
fabiano will be convinced and live up to
his promise
and i want to start with a game that i
played against fabi just other day
because we went into
a kind of a typical line this bishop c5
bishop e2 line
and during our game i
i took a risk i played h5
which
i know is a dubious move and from here
fabiano actually played brilliantly i
don't think he made a single mistake or
an accuracy and just
uh yeah was up a pawn he even gave the
pawn back but got a commanding position
never let the advantage slip
but already after bishop e2
black has a chance to equalize and black
can play queen d4
hitting f2 hitting e4
and after castling
there is
knight takes e4 and if we ask the engine
okay maybe white has some slight
advantage but this is already very close
to quality for black
where um
at the top level you should be pretty
pleased with the opening outcome
now we discussed after our game
that there's also this move here h5
which maybe i also could have gone into
uh after which yeah d3 and white still
has an advantage
what i didn't tell fabi was there's a
really really cool
um
double piece sacrifice line
and we just scraped the surface of it so
i actually want to show it here because
it's a line that isn't so easy to spot
even at like grandmaster level
especially in the blitz game
um it's after h3
we can see the engine points out black
is already
pretty much winning here
but the line itself is actually really
beautiful of course black starting uh f2
pawn and after takes takes
it looks like white has a defense with
g3 to prepare king g2 and rook h1
but then after queen e5 king g2
it's black to move and win
and
this is one of the reasons why i like to
play the stafford gambit myself
is for opportunities like this where you
can
uh chuck pieces at the opponent
and uh in this case it's already
completely winning for black
there's a line after king f2 rook h2
king e3 queen g3 king d4 bishop e6
preparing queenside castle with check
and uh yeah white's pretty much getting
mated here
um so this is just one of so many
potential landmines that white can fall
into
and if you're gonna play this on a title
tuesday and you don't wanna
necessarily take the risk uh there is
queen d4 which is very close equalizing
but i want to share some other examples
of top players
playing against the staffer gambit and
stumbling and
against an unprepared opponent
it's possible to
to emerge okay as black
this is a game that i played a few
months ago against levon aronian
and i should note we were playing on
this chessup board video is on my
channel so i was getting some assistance
from the smart board
but we went into a line that a lot of
strong players will go into this bishop
e3 move
maybe similar to the game i played
against fabi um but maybe a little bit
different too because the knight hasn't
committed to c3
and just watch how quickly i was able to
equalize here
by just playing natural moves uh h file
opened
ironian played queen d2 and after queen
d6
it's already very difficult for white to
defend h-pawn
and maybe there's some way for white to
keep some advantage
um yeah g3s will only move but a lot of
players will be discouraged to play g3
because it walks into this
and black has one back upon and reaches
some end game that
um should be holdable maybe still better
for white but uh
it's arguably an opening success
uh given that the staff of gambo was
played
in this game queen c3 was played and
this just led to a drawing line after
takes takes takes
uh it was white who eventually had to
force
perpetual
with uh queen g a queen g5
and this was a
pretty straightforward draw against one
of the top players in the world now i
want to move on and show a game
which is probably the most notable
stafford gambit game in any title
tuesday ever
in which komsky lost
to v pranav
in just 17 moves
and this is another example of just the
venom of the stafford
um they went into this line e2 h5 h3 and
the move to start with here is queen d4
now carlson actually had this position
on lee chess
at some point i'm not sure if it will
show up in the database but uh carlson
played bishop e3 here
can we find dr nitrostein
uh as white
and
yeah carlson ended up winning this game
but
even magnus
did not get an advantage against the
stafford after just eight moves after
queen b2
knight d2 bishop e3 fe3 black's
completely fine queen e5
and it's probably white who has to be
very careful here like a move like
castling and just loses to bishop h3
and in this game knight f3 was played
and after queen g3
uh king f1
black doesn't have any problems like h4
and maybe go for this idea
so
um just more inspiration that uh magnus
well it was not better after he played
bishop e3 of course the best move here
and that's what kamsky played this is
the castle
and from here we're gonna see a really
cool attacking sequence from black i
could leave the engine open
um i know it's it's it's losing for
black objectively according to stock
fish but all it takes is one mistake
from white one natural looking move uh
intending to try and help defend the
king side
and here amazingly queen g3 is uh is
just kind of a crushing blow threatening
this and there's no great defense best
move is king h1 which walks into bishop
f2
this was not played in the game
but instead bishop takes h3 was played
and
pranav got still a crushing attack after
another mistake from kamsky
and the finish this game was just
absolutely brutal
we see black's menacing attack on the
king side
and
yeah this is gg
so i could go on and on with example
games
some of which i might not get to
but i want to share some more
inspiration and just share some analysis
that maybe isn't so easy to find if
you're just studying the position
with stockfish from here uh because i
know there's so many moves that are uh
are better for white are objectively
winning but sometimes in life you do
have to
do some dubious things to have a little
bit more fun
now if there's any small children
watching this doesn't apply to you
but
let me just share some fun trappy lines
that even title players will fall into
this was a game i played against nemo
wgm nimo zhao
which went uh along another common line
that a lot of players played bishop to
e3
uh we can see in the database as we've
played many times before
after takes takes knight g4
the most common line that white will
play is queen f3
and after queen g5 king d2
there is a
really nice idea here from black
knight takes h2 with a point after rook
takes h2 queen e5
essentially winning material white is
guaranteed to lose one of the rooks
and so many title players have fallen
for this against me in the past
if we just see the database
um
yeah black is is winning here okay i
haven't won all the games but uh
it's it's a nice one to know and even
going back like bishop e3
um white's only slightly better
uh like queen f4 is the best move which
isn't played too often and then there's
h6 which is an interesting line and um
very few people will actually find king
d2 which is the best move in this
position
so moving on
uh i want to share just some other
simple ideas that will trap even strong
players
f3 is a move that stockfish gives as a
refutation to the staffer gambit but
after bishop's e6 this is a move i uh
discovered from jonathan trance it leads
to a position
where the two most common moves played
online are both blunders both d4 and c3
walk into the same tactical idea knight
takes e4
after takes queen h4 g3 queen takes e4
black's winning the rook and the point
of bishop e6 was that after queen e2
uh this is no longer this pin so the
queen is free to take the rook
um of course white is better if white
plays some unnatural move
like uh like maybe queen e2 or okay
knight c3 also fine move but bishop c5
there is some some still potential play
for uh for messiness going into the
middle game let me give a few more lines
uh this kingy four line which i
discussed with fabi
um
after our our game the other day is if
white plays h3 takes takes takes
uh if king g1 black forces a draw
king e3
then yeah then there's a lot of fun to
be had even though the engine says
white's still better here i think
casting is just leads to a very
difficult position for white to play and
there's some fun lines here like queen
h4 king f3 queen h5 just follow the
engine line it's actually a cool line
bishop g4
and queen h1
uh king f2 only moved to survive and
then f5
and um yeah black's definitely not worse
here
um i want to share a trap that caro fell
into
in a speed run
uh he just walked straight into this
line i'll have to dig up the speed run
video i think he had some some weird
username
go here
i'm actually in trouble this game which
is pretty funny okay
this guy is smurf but uh he played d3 in
this position which just walks into
knight g4
and i've had countless
animes fm's even ions and
even hikaru fell into this
and black's already better
white has to play bishop e3 and after
takes takes takes
engine is giving already a substantial
uh plus for for black
so i don't want to make this video too
long but uh let me just share a few
bonus traps
and
i think the the main line i want to
share
that would appeal to a super gm
is a line that stockfish doesn't fully
understand and it happens in one of the
so-called refutation lines after d3
bishop c5
um i haven't actually talked about c3
but c3 walks into a cool idea knight e4
queen e2 bishop f2 king d1 f5
um which is slightly better for white
but there's definitely compensation here
for black
most people will play bishop e2 and
after h5
play c3
and for a while this was considered to
be
the main refutation
but about a year and a half ago jonathan
trance came out with a video in which he
nearly beat stockfish
with the black side of this position and
he discovered a truly magical line which
goes knight g4
d4 engine already
was giving like plus four there
uh but after queen h4 g3
queen to f6
um
the nature of the position
is very very complicated i i think that
the engine evaluation doesn't actually
reflect how tricky this position can be
for white
uh if we just turn the engine off for a
moment let me show one of the the cool
lines actually show um a game i played
against gm serrano
in the title tuesday we got to this
position
and i proceeded to
go for um
this line that jonathan trons plays
in this video where he takes on
stockfish
is to go for rook h2
lose a bishop and then play bishop e6
and we leave the knight hanging
the most natural looking move is queen
d4
and an incredible move here bishop to c4
and uh this is the engine top move
engine will still say white's winning
here
but come on look at this move it's
amazing if queen takes c4 there's
already 95 black's not worse
what happened this game is okay white
took i play knight e5
knight d2 take on d2 i win the queen
white's still better but all it takes is
one
slip up bishop s7 was mistake and then i
went on to win this game
and even if white plays the best move
rook h1
i think practically there is still
chances for black to fight in in the
blitz game
with um the queen and rook in a pretty
open position
um
so going back i want to share one more
cool variation in
this line
and it's actually a game that i played
against some anonymous i am
on
lead chess it was against an i am
uh by the name of half natty
um
and we went into the same line
and this time white takes on g4
and we got to a position where
i end up sacrificing two pieces white
takes
engine will of course say white is like
plus five
but uh
if you ask leela lilo will say like
plus two or three
so i know it's still like considered
winning for whites but if you actually
look at the lines after bishop e6 knight
d2 castling white's a little bit stuck
like the top moves for engine or like b3
rook c1 a4 g5 it's like moves that don't
really accomplish much
and white's actually kind of stuck here
like it's an interesting position to try
and figure out what's going on
i think there's some plan for black like
if white just wastes time on the queen
side there's f6 g6 f5 eventually
to try and open things up
um this game featured a nice finish
after queen a4
black's already winning with rookie two
and the king got hunted and there's no
good way to stop queenie two so
i don't want to make this video too long
if you made this far
congratulations on having a long
attention span and maybe
staying with me and giving me some of
your attention
uh fabiano if you're watching this
i really hope that you
[Music]
change your mind
and play the stafford
but it's completely okay to be patient
and wait for the right opportunity wait
for the right opponent to play it
against who maybe
you suspect won't be watching
this video or just my content on youtube
so with that um
i
i guess i forgive you for
your vile words from earlier
and hopefully we can still be friends
and also subscribe to the c-squared
podcast
my interview with thumb will drop
tomorrow on their channel
we had an almost 90 minute talk
discussed a lot of cool things
uh relatively drama free but a ton of
fun stories
and uh yeah stay tuned for that
i hope you guys enjoy subscribe to
c-squared and i'll see you guys soon